nhưng mà các lãnh nào đàn nhờ nước, chân trọng chào dành hợp ánh hôm lực lượng
bú trang nhân dân tạng lực lượng bú trang của tù chính,
tổ mi tư tố lâm chút mơm những chiến công thành tích caul lớn,
sự lớn mạnh của lực lượng bú trang của tù, đồng thời,
nhấn mạnh bước vào giải đạn phát triển mới,
tình hình thế giới và khu vực có những diễn biến nhân chống,
tất tạp, có dựa đoán với các thích thức ăn linh truyền thống và phía trường thống,
đặc biệt là bánh đe biến đổi khí hậu, nước biển dân,
giấm nhập mạnh đáng tắc động sức sắc đến gồng bằng xung của lâm.
Giờ đó, giọng vụ bảo vệ tổ quốc, giọng vụ xe dựng quân độ nói chung,
và cuộc quân của chỉ nói dân,
đàn ra những yêu cầu ngày khang caul.
Thử dân tới để hoàn thành tốt chức năng, giọng vụ của đơn vị các chiếm dịch chính lượng của bệnh cuối phòng,
trên địa bàn trọng hiểu phía tây năm của đơn nước,
tổ mi tư tố lâm, biệt thương của nguy trung hương đề nghỉ.
Tức tục phán chết sâu sắc tư tưởng quân sự hộ chimêng,
đơn lối quân sự quốc phòng của đàn nhất là chính lượng bảo vệ tổ quốc trong tình mới,
và các đột phá đã được sắc định trong nghỉ quyết tại hội đàn bộ quân của chính lần thứ mề hồn,
và đại hội đàn bộ quân đội lần thứ mì hai.
Nắng cao chân lận tổ hợp, sức mạnh trên đấu,
đàn kết cân mò với thúc yーチ in quyền, giấm dân các diệu thương,
nắm chắc, giữ đảo đúng tình hình,
làm tốt tổng các tham yーチ lực với quân yーチu ngần, bộ quốc phòng,
xây dựng cùng cố nền của phòng tần dân,
thử chận của phòng tần dân bộ mạnh,
gắn với thẻ chẳng ám lình ngần dân,
xây dựng của vực phòng thủ vẫn chắc,
tạo thế chủ đầu,
làm thích bải mọi em như trong phá của các thẻ lực thủ đệ,
giữ vực mọi trường hoa vình,
or định trên địa bàn và chủ quyền của đàn nhất,
tổng mì thư yêu cầu,
tập trông xây dựng lực lượng của chăng của quốc chiến các mạnh chính quyền,
tình về, giảnh đại,
lấy xây dựng về chính trị,
làm cơn dựng ở năng cao chất lượng tổng hợp,
và sức mạnh trên đấu,
quán trị tư tưởng người trước xú sau của chú tích vụ chimêng,
tập trung đổi mấy năng cao chất lượng của lượng trên đấu,
gián lượng năng cao bản lính,
thế chất và chính đổ kỹ thuật,
xếng thuật,
tổng mì thư nhận mạnh,
làm chủ vụ khí,
chẳng bì nhất là vụ khí mấy,
diễn đại,
sẵn sẵn sẵn trên đấu và chính thẵn trông mọi điều kiện,
mọi thình hốn và các hình thái chân xanh mấy,
chẳng không dàn phát triển mấy,
tình ghiên và nhận vụ mấy,
cân đặc biệt chú trọng năng cao chình đổ kho học,
công nghệ trong bộ nội,
trong công tác của lượng,
sẵn sẵn sẵn trên đấu,
cân hình hình hình thúc chất,
gián lượng thúc chất,
tình hốn thúc chất,
để trên đấu và chính thẵn trông mọi thình hốn,
tổ mì thư yêu cầu,
lượng quân khu chiến thử xuyên làm tốt công tác dân vật,
tăng cường cùng của mối quan hệ bản khách,
gắn mỏ với quân dân,
xây dựng thử chất lòng dân bự chất,
kết hợp chặt chẽ nhận vụ cùng của khu phòng ann,
với phát triển kinh đe xa hội,
tương hiển có nhiều quả các dự án tình tế của phòng trên đều bàn,
tương viện tốt công tác chính xách,
tích cử thăm ra khách hoàn đầu ăn xin xa hội,
luôn xuống đầu,
sẵn sẵn sẵn thăm ra dút,
yên dân phòng,
chống khách vụ khổ quả tiên tay,
dịch bệ,
quân khu chiến phải là lưỡng tinh vệ,
là chỗ dựa tin kệ của nhân dân trên mặt trạng này,
trong gia đình kinh mạng mới,
căn cân phát triển thống bệ văn,
giận vụ nào cũng ngon thành,
có con nào cũng vượt qua,
kẻ thù nào cũng đánh thắng,
thức sự là đổi quân trên đấu,
đổi quân công tác,
đổi thuân lâu đậu sẵn xuất của quân đội,
nhân dân bình đám án hồng.
Tổng miếng thư yêu cầu,
trên khai thực hiện tháng lời nghĩ quyết đại hội đảng bộ quân khu,
nghĩ quyết đảng hội đảng bộ quân đội,
và nghĩ quyết đại hội đảng tòan khu vận thức mềm bộ,
các nghĩ quyết của bộ chính trị mới bàn hành trong năm 2020,
cũng như các chính trình hành đầu,
sát mấy tình hình dọng vụ quân sự,
cũng bảo vệ lực lượng,
cũng trang quân khu và tình hình trên đệ bàn.
Tập trung xe dự đảng bộ quân khu vận vệ vệ chính trị,
tư tưởng đậu đất,
tổ chức và cán mộ,
đệ mạnh hông tập và làm theo tư tưởng đậu đất,
phong cách tự xin mình,
khu vấn đẩu phát triển thống,
có nghĩa tài năng,
sứng dành bộ đội của hồ thơ khi mới,
sây dự đổi ngần cán mộ,
chứ thế là cán mộ chủ trí các cấp,
cán mộ thăm nơi trị dịch,
thức sự tư biểu về phẩm chất,
nhẹ bán sát sảo,
lĩnh hoạch trong năm 2020,
sự lĩnh tình hình và có trình đồ,
năng lực thăm mêu,
đứng dẫn,
trịnh hai thực hiện tháng lợi mọi nhiều bộ,
dịm này,
tổ biệt tư tổ lâm,
cũng yêu cầu,
tích tục thử dẫn có nhiều quả nhận bụ,
đối ngoại thuốc phòng với côn đổi phẳng ra,
và hướng cốm cầm buổi chiê,
với hợp với các lượng của bục phòng,
trong công tác đối ngoại thuốc phòng,
nhất là người khác nước ASEAN,
nắm chấp tình lình có liên quan,
chù động tháng viên chính lực,
sự biệt kiến quyết,
con khéo khắc quân nề về biên dưới,
biển đào,
đối tranh làm thích bại mọi emm yêu,
tụi đàn chống phá,
đây trình dễ phón hệ giữa Việt Nam với công buổi chiê và cân nước trong ASEAN,
chứ đó tổ miếng tư tổ lâm,
đường liển chú tịch hồi chiếm miên trong quân viên của côn cù chiến,
trong khổ bị trang nghiêm,
tổ miếng tư tụi đàn chống tác,
và các đại biểu đã bày tỏ lòng thánh kính,
tưởng nhớ và chiến,
đối với công lao to lấn của chú tịch hồi chiếm miên bị đại,
và các emm yêu lửa sĩ,
với lòng thánh kính và biết ơn buồn hạn,
đoàn chống tác về hợp tập,
và làm thêm thích tưởng đợt lức con cách hồi chiếm miên,
đoàn thiết một lòng,
tình lối chung thánh với đàn,
với tổ quốc và nhìn dân,
khoảng thánh xuất sắc mọi nhận buộc được rao,
góc phần xây dựng đất nước hại càng phôn viên, giờ mạnh.